all right Louis we did a big expose on
the Islamist apologetics of reza aslan
we did a huge expose on the regressive
left we've talked about how all
religions must be open for criticism and
self-actualized self-actualized
societies there should be no topics
off-limits we shouldn't use allegations
of bigotry or racism to shut down debate
on important issues we've talked about
all that right we've made it very very
clear we've even been criticized for
some of those things we've said but
sometimes people are just plain stupid
and ignorant and oftentimes that
ignorant is based in xenophobia or
discrimination or racism and it can be
pretty clear and I'm talking about the
story of an Ivy League economist who was
profiled and interrogated for doing math
on a flight where an ignorant woman
thought he was writing foreign letters
possibly Arabic which by the way would
be allowed on planes anyway this is an
unbelievable story I'm talking about 40
year-old economist from UPenn the
University of Pennsylvania and Ivy
League school guido men's EO he boarded
a regional jet okay to fly from
Philadelphia to Syracuse he was wearing
jeans and a red Lacoste sweater nothing
out of the ordinary he got on the plane
and he was scribbling on a notepad and
seated next to him is a 30 something
year old woman who looks over and she's
unsettled by the man scribbling stuff
that looked a little bit strange to her
she tried to make conversation and the
Ivy League economist reportedly wasn't
very interested in talking to her
the woman ends up flagging down a flight
attendant and passing her a note which
she scribbled down on her own piece of
paper and then the plane seemingly
didn't leave the gate didn't go anywhere
the flight attendant ended up coming
back over to the woman and asked if
should the woman felt okay to fly or if
she was too sick the woman said no I'm
okay to fly but something about it
apparently didn't sound right to the
flight attendant which led to American
Airlines flight 39 50 staying on the
ground eventually the plane after having
left the gate turned around and went
back to the gate and the woman I've told
you about was asked
ordered off the plane the waiting
continued not much of an explanation and
then the pilot comes by approaches the
dark darkly complected man darkly
complexed how do you say that he had a
dark complexion is what I'm getting at
this foreign man and he was escorted off
of the plane and then he met some sort
of agent it's not clear whether this was
somebody affiliated with the airline or
law enforcement or who and he was asked
about his seat mate the woman the Ivy
Lee economist said I don't know she was
acting a little bit funny she didn't
seem visibly ill I don't know I guess
the authorities just have questions for
me about this woman and then the real
reason for the delay comes to the
surface the woman saw something Lewis
and she decided to say something this
man was scribbling it looked like
foreign letters could have been Arabic
who knows what it was this could be
someone who is a terrorist in the end
the alleged foreign lettering turned out
to be nothing but differential equations
Lewis math men's EO showed the
authorities his calculations he was
allowed to get back on the plane the
woman never came back to the plane this
woman is a victim of both ignorance and
fear mongering paranoid propaganda
there's no doubt about it however we
also really have an issue here of just
just plain old-fashioned stupidity right
I mean we have a guy doing math on the
plane and that foreign lettering makes
this guy a terrorism suspect yeah this
is I understand the fear part of things
in some ways the terrorists have won
because that fear has been instilled in
so many Americans right when you get on
a plane sure but you have to draw a line
somewhere and and stupid takes over at a
certain point and and airlines should
really have like a protocol for
determining when stupid is happening yet
and when stupid is over the stupidness
is just overwhelming but think about it
Dave to a woman as stupid and ignorant
as this yeah math basically is terrorism
well that's what I started thinking of
which is well hold on a second
if you don't realize that even if this
liked it let's and let's imagine the
nightmare scenario this guy is sitting
on a plane doing math but it's the math
for a bomb this is the math that's going
to be used to set off a bomb we also
have another layer of ignorance which is
none of the 9/11 hijackers were dressed
in ways that were particularly Muslim
they were know that they were trained
and how to sort of blend in they had
shaved beard they did not have beers
they had shaved faces etc etc you're not
gonna plan the attack on a cocktail
napkin that they give you with your
peanuts on the plane if you're trying to
blow up the plane and so there's
multiple levels of ignorance here mm-hmm
so I some people just give in to the
fear way more than others some people
are way more susceptible this is
probably a woman who's afraid of
everything all the time and not just
Muslim terrorists I've met people like
this yeah and it just seems like a
really horrible way to live your life